we got matheus this is look at this guy
stealing black people's names first of
all he's from Belgium banana right but
he is Pavlov Mattias sounds like a
quarterback for LSU is that a ponytail
at the back is it the holy bad year that
you what's up Brandon I'm Matthias you
can call me Manny I'm from Belgium but
I'm coming to you from well at rescue
centre in Ecuador the animals here are
brought in by the police confiscated by
out of the black market most of them
were bats illegally owned however I know
Danny u.s. depending on the state where
you are it's legal to own exotic pets
and I wanted to know your thoughts about
it so Oh
exile beds or stinging with that it's on
highway 9 so muchas gracias amigo dude
King exotic animals yellow metal though
dude white people take it too far
like that guy in New York who had a
tiger and a crocodile in this [ __ ]
apartment they start fighting it to rush
out the goddamn building yeah I've seen
that dude so bad idea you just fell
asleep eat you mangia
oh you're right you're right that's
coming hard you're like dude when you're
right you're right when you're right
you're right dude hi I mixed the round
also you're hanging out with Ari Shaffir
dudes lace in your afternoon
[Laughter]
unfortunately watch Jumanji this is
beautiful I don't even
that a lemur here's some big old eyes
nothing looks like use twisting his
nipples - wow that thing I'll climb -
touch you man thing beautiful
that's not sugar you know what you want
to marry this bum well just problem the
monkey has a side piece I don't know if
they're in a relationship
yeah what is monkeys AHA says in a
relationship on Facebook
the monkey won't stop cheating on him
he's hard to do well here's the thing I
think Matthias for uhm in America I
think a lot of people have started to
get a lot of people get animals and they
I think they they just don't take they
they're not prepared to take care of
them that's well no cuz you by a
crocodile when they're young like oh
this is cool saltwater croc now I'm
leaving my bathtub six months go by the
things I'll [ __ ] crocodile can't take
a [ __ ] anymore
think it through
also exotic animals this day and age
yeah you know in America we're always
trying to one-up each other we're trying
to flash it that used to be Rams used to
be dope cars dope houses now next thing
you know they got a guy in Cleveland
with three girls locked in his basement
for a decade he's like oh come over and
see these crazy lizard humans painted
scales on one of them so that's a diva
but scales up that's I think within
America we've gone past the point of
like what's the like real purpose of it
and more to the point of like how can we
make it and like you know what I'm
saying I'm doing it for the gram these
yeah this is trying to get likes like
some dude by the high you know the other
day and walked it down the street that
ain't safe bro yeah that ain't safe yeah
you can't be heaven you can't be doing
hyena but hahaha dude you know there's
nobody nobody your neighborhood has a
hey NAT hanging a defense kit you know
yeah but also don't bring your hanging a
dog parking like just a bull man
I'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] I've ever seen
one problem yeah why is it laughing over
there by the fence
yeah just gives your favorite movies
black pants that doesn't mean you have
to buy one on the black market man
things are dangerous
yeah dude why are they watching The Lion
King and drawing a [ __ ] evil plan if
it's a Bullmastiff but look man I think
I think Americans were becoming an
endangered species in some way do we
need to be rescued brah
so I think we could use probably you
know I'd be in a while being a woman's
shirt I wouldn't hide in a man's shirt
like that the animal but I think it's
beautiful what you guys are doing over
there yeah I want mine like an armadillo
but yeah people are getting Tigers
people are getting elephants people are
getting people you know it's getting
spooky man sex trafficking is big over
here they say it's big did they say it's
bumper-to-bumper I haven't seen one
person next abuts bro you know nuts too
but all the women that I meet just want
to be hookers I agree it's like that's
the job you don't but every now and then
I guess there's one that's you know
caught up in a dope game and they're
being abused but just don't [ __ ] any of
these animals bro
yeah I'm just saying I want armadillo so
we could get like a mascot for the
studio what could it be what about a bat
just [ __ ] flies on [ __ ] everywhere
we're just like goddamn them can't sting
it all right dude I'm just [ __ ]
everywhere yeah
guano guano
I think every night what is that guano
he's not sure - oh yeah yeah man I think
um and what does this guy want to do he
wants to bring this into the country no
I just wanted the King ever sing it do
you guys like it remember when Bieber
got stopped in like Australia or some
[ __ ] he had that pet monkey Romare that
yeah he's a pet monkey Timon check that
thing dude how could you not have a fat
monkey in Australia there's so many
animals there everything is oh dude I
should have a call off the street come
on our dragons dude they got everything
over there yeah we could use a mascot in
here though maybe an ant farm see
monkeys I suggest a bat yeah just rats
and bees or maybe an Isis somebody's
been in Isis and we could freaking slap
them time up yeah feed them dirty Fritos
yeah
you have another boy have another beat
up a son but yeah man thank you for
sending in thank you for watching this
in another country bro yeah man Philly's
um feliza
not not it's not Christmas yet we're
literally el dia de los muertos bien
bien want to have a good Halloween
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]